[Musique]
oubliez croyez vous qu'il y ait de pata
plus je ne vous trompez pas voter bien
sûr photo ce contenu attention il me
manque
coupant les pattes de vitesse
bien sûr ça n'existe pas en grand modèle
mais peut-être qu'en tirant un peu
dessus j'arrive à les mettre
et c'est de la provocation au seulement
j'avais mon illustré
dans un sac à papier les voilà partis
tout seul merci le vote
maintenant j'en vois un pain au chocolat
je sois le plus beau pas tendu
on arrive à ça c'est de l'obéissance où
je ne m'y connais pas il me faut des
potes de vitesse par n'importe quel
moyen
marcil à battre maintenant on va
s'arranger un peu un jeu 100 pages
[Musique]
je n'y tiens
à
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je ne suis pas sûr je n'ai subi rabat
béchard
[Musique]
et maintenant un mois la grande vie
[Rires]
voyons le problème et ne pas les lâcher
ensemble car elle s'enfuiraient pour
rejoindre pâte à zulte
bon je n'aurai donc une esclave au lieu
de deux ecoute-moi bottes
j'aimerais bien lire mon journal mon
journal nous sens à homer qui est le
battre ici
mais il est tout déchirer essayons autre
chose un bon cigare et je serai le plus
heureux des bougon ça marche au quart de
tour
gros tapis bonhomme une moitié de
cigares mais ça me suffit pas si vous
voulez un journal au plat ou un cigare
tout entre il faut en voisin le buck et
bien bon c'est pas ta zut je me vois
obligé de te demander pardon mais
j'avais tellement envie de ses bottes
cet oubli nous allons fêter ça on peut
vendre 20 la limonade
en asie les bottes sotra plaisir de
travailler avec toi
batta zut déjà c'est bon la limonade
d'unimail convié 3g vous qu'il y ait de
pâte à puch qu'il ne faut trop d'écho
notez bien sur vos droits votre
attention
[Musique]